well today the FDA is meeting for a
second day to address the possible risks
of breast implants the agency reported
last fall that 457 cases of cancer have
been detected in women with breast
implants and a Warner has been reporting
on this issue since 2017
now she spoke with the plastic surgeon
about the potential risks certain
implants may pose and a good morning
good morning more than 10 million women
have breast implants and one particular
type of implant is causing the concern
here some women with textured implants
have developed a type of cancer called
lymphoma it was thought to be easily
curable but one Texas woman's case
raises new questions about just how
deadly that cancer might be Sandra Rush
is a grandmother who'd had breast
implants for more than two decades with
no issues until April of 2017 my left
breast
began to swell and there was a hardness
in it what her doctor at first thought
was a common infection turned out to be
cancer I was in shock really I couldn't
I couldn't believe it
it's called breast implant Associated
anaplastic large cell lymphoma a rare
cancer the FDA says can develop
following breast implants most women who
get that cancer like rush have what are
called textured breast implants these
shaped implants have a rougher surface
that's designed to limit the movement of
an implant but may also initiate the
cancer breast surgeon Elizabeth Potter
is Russia's doctor is one of the
theories that this just kind of
irritates and inflames the surrounding
tissues it is one of the theories
because of this surface phase right
that's right
reports to the FDA show of 457 cancer
cases at least 310 occurred with
textured implants most women are cured
after doctors take the implants out but
in Sandra Russia's case after her
implants were removed and she'd had
breast reconstruction she developed an
on pain in her jaw so doctors did
another test it showed that it had
metastasized all through my body I can't
imagine what that feeling is like
I wasn't complete at her shock I was
incomplete at her shock she wasn't the
only one when I got the pathology report
I was astonished I actually thought it
was incorrect really I read it and
reread it the cancer had moved beyond
the area of the implant into her tissues
and bones and this was not something
that you expected to see I'd never heard
of that and did not expect it was not
taught that that could happen
not only was Russia's cancer not easily
curable it could kill her
Potter says it took five rounds of
chemotherapy and a stem cell transplant
to put her into remission we have seen
something new and breast implant
associated cancer and I just want us to
pay attention to that it was just an
awful experience really bad the
country's three largest breast implant
manufacturers told us textured implants
have been extensively tested for safety
and comply with FDA monitoring and that
patient safety is their top priority
mentor says the cancer risk is rare with
its implants but that's not good enough
for dr. Potter she won't use them
anymore
I won't place them and actually in my
practice we often say if this doesn't
pass the sister test doesn't pass the
sister test ie that's can give it to
your sister you're not going to give it
to your patients that's correct
dr. Potter now specializes in using a
woman's own belly fat to reconstruct a
new breast instead of using implants if
a patient wants a non textured implant
she'll provide it but says the power
should be in the woman's hands let's
give her the information and let her
choose this implant carries greater risk
would you like it in your body it's that
simple
you're in remission that's incredible
last month rush got a clean bill of
health from her oncologist but regrets
the day nearly a quarter century ago
when she decided she needed breast
implants
I think women kind of get conditioned in
their mind
that you know they want to look a
certain way because that's the way you
should look and like me I mean I paid
for it
more ways than one well today the FDA
will be hearing more stories from
patients and advocates in the second day
of the hearing on the safety of breast
implants I'm happy to hear that Sandra
is in remission but of course no one
wants to go through what she experienced
so should women who have these textured
implants should they have them removed
just preemptively now so of course
that's a conversation between a woman
and her doctor but depending on which
doctor you talk to for example dr.
Potter says that she would advise women
to think about having them removed
that's coming from her but it's
something that women she thinks should
think about but definitely something to
talk about with their doctor is on an
individual case-by-case basis for sure
and even though it's a rarity according
to your story it still is a very scary
thing that you think why would you even
want to take any kind of chance well
that's the thing and they say that most
women can be cured by removing it the
implant and the capsule the tissue
around but the question raised of course
by it ms russia's case is you know would
it spread into the rest of the body
which is obviously a very scary question
the idea of taking your own fat as a
breast implant is interesting yeah it's
called deep flap it's something that I
had never heard of neither or literally
where they you they do a tummy tuck
they take that flap of fat etc and they
create a breast reconstruction with it
and dr. Potter's a huge fan she does it
she says she has patients fly in to do
it we're talking about that next series
about that thank you very much